llega el momento de repasar las
principales noticias económicas aquí en
directo a América de france24 para ello
contamos hoy un día más con nuestro
compañero Jorge Hurtado bienvenido Jorge
muy bien Rodrigo Bueno vamos a hablar
empezando a hablar de la Cumbre
climática Perdón financiera global de
París que reunió a líderes mundiales
instituciones también internacionales y
ongs pero también se habló del clima fue
uno de los ejes principales Y es que
unos 40 líderes entre ellos varias
docenas de África también presidentes
latinoamericanos y el Primer Ministro de
China se reunieron para definir esta
nueva agenda financiera global las
naciones más ricas del mundo prometieron
financiar
climáticamente o o financiación para el
clima en 100 mil millones de dólares en
derechos especiales de giro esto para
los países en desarrollo y crearon
también un fondo para la biodiversidad y
la protección de los bosques los
derechos especiales de giro dan acceso a
los activos de reserva internacional que
están en poder del fondo monetario
internacional y que se cambiar por
moneda también prometieron 200 mil
millones de dólares de capacidad
crediticia adicional Durante los
próximos años Colombia Kenia y Francia
propusieron que se evalúe como la
revisión de la deuda podría ayudar a los
países de renta media y baja a financiar
los objetivos climáticos hay también
estuvo presente el presidente colombiano
Gustavo Petro que dijo que impulsará
esta propuesta de cambiar deuda por
acción climática en la reunión entre
líderes europeos y latinoamericanos
prevista para Julio de este año pese a
la tímida acogida que tuvo esta idea en
París escuchemos que decía el presidente
Petro pero la posición de cambiar deuda
por acción temática ya es de Suramérica
ahora vamos a conversarlo en un entorno
un poco más amplio que la celac
latinoamérica y el Caribe
Barbados
que va hacia una reunión Cumbre ahora en
julio con la Unión Europea y yo espero
que esa propuesta se coloque en la mesa
de discusión entre Unión Europea y se la
Me parece que la propuesta en bloques
mucho más eficaz que un acuerdo
bilateral entre dos países
que perdería todo sentido político
aunque tenga algún sentido económico
para los países que estarían ahí pues
Jorge veremos si avanza esa propuesta en
bloque que quiere Gustavo Petro nos
vamos ahora hasta Turquía allí la lira
parece que sigue bajando ha llegado a un
nuevo mínimo histórico bueno superó la
Barrera de 25 unidades por dólar y el
desplome comenzó ayer tras anunciarse
una subida de los tipos de interés del
Banco Central menor de lo que esperaba
el mercado la lira perdió un 1,7% en las
últimas horas ahora la moneda de Turquía
anota un 20% de pérdida desde que el
presidente erdogan fue reelegido el
pasado 28 de mayo para un nuevo mandato
de cinco años como presidente de esa
nación la subida de 6,5 puntos en los
tipos de interés que ahora se ubiquen
hasta el 15% fue la primera en dos años
y debería haber servido para incentivar
el ahorro Y de alguna forma estabilizar
esta moneda pero ocurrió todo lo
contrario y bueno Jorge mientras en
malas noticias para los turcos Hay
buenas noticias para quien poseen
bitcoin porque ha vuelto a subir Bueno
la moneda digital superó los 31 mil
dólares su máximo desde de este año y su
nivel más alto desde junio del 2022
según los datos de bloomberg El
criptoactivo subió casi un 90% desde
principios de este año pero aún está un
50% por debajo de su máximo histórico de
casi 69 mil dólares ese mercado ya había
sido dado casi por muerto para muchos
tras una serie de estafas de alto perfil
y de caídas de empresas que dejaron Al
sector bastante golpeado para los
expertos la inflación las crisis
bancarias la crisis duda soberana y
también las dudas sobre el estado de las
reservas de dólares estadounidenses
refuerzan la teoría de una economía
descentralizada con la que justamente
nacieron las criptomonedas Jorge Pues
vamos a terminar hablando de Estados
Unidos y de las huelgas que parece que
va a haber en la cadena Starbucks bueno
el sindicato de baristas de la cadena de
cafeterías convocó a una huelga tras la
denuncia de que la empresa había
prohibido la decoración del mes del
orgullo en algunas de sus cafeterías del
sindicato pretende también presionar a
la empresa para cerrar contratos
laborales que mejoren los salarios y las
prestaciones más de 3000 trabajadores de
más de 150 establecimientos abandonarán
sus puestos la próxima semana la huelga
se va a realizar durante un fin de
semana o previo el fin de semana de
celebraciones del mes del orgullo en
Estados Unidos con desfiles en ciudades
importantes como Nueva York San
Francisco Seattle y Chicago la empresa
dice que estas acusaciones de que ya
había prohibido las decoraciones son
falsas bueno
Jorge Pues muchas gracias por este
repaso económico te invito a que sigas
con nosotros que ya llega una semana en
el mundo con nuestra compañera Rosa
Pérez gracias vale